[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le mardi
15 décembre tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité locale
à dix jours de noël le conseil
scientifique préconise le recours à des
tests au co vie de 19 dans certains cas
avant d'aller réveillonner les campagnes
de dépistage se multiplient dans le même
temps dans le sud yvelines une tania
hausse va sillonner 16 communes pour
tester les habitants en zone rurale
l'édition 2010 est certes terminée mais
les dons sont toujours possibles pour le
téléthon le week-end dernier à
guyancourt l'association jardins
passions partage à préparer des repas à
emporter aux bénéfices de l'événement de
mobilisation contre les maladies
génétiques rares
enfin tendance à la fin de ce journal
quels sont les jouets ou jeux qui seront
au pied du sapin cette année
reportage dans une enseigne spécialisée
à montigny le bretonneux et nous
prendrons également le contre-pied dans
cette édition à parlant du jouet ancien
avec un spécialiste basé à versailles
françois binétruy
mais avant de développer ces titres il
lançait le mois dernier leur appel du 14
novembre une centaine de maires et élus
locaux demandé au gouvernement est
d'attribuer au moins 1 % du plan de
relance du gouvernement d'un montant
d'un milliard d'euros aux quartiers
populaires alors que le projet de loi
finances 2021 sera votée à l'assemblée
nationale ce jeudi ses élus ont fait
part des avancées au cours d'une
conférence de presse
interview collectées par astrid bergère
[Musique]
nous avons été reçus donc par gérard
larcher et puis parce que sénateur alors
le site n'a vraiment montré la voie il a
montré la voie parce que toutes
tendances politiques confondues
nous avons non seulement été écoutés
mais très vite les sénateurs se sont
donnés le moyen de nous accompagner sur
nos premières demandes et nous
accompagner en urgence le sénat a
considéré qu'il était nécessaire de
débloquer au moins 500 millions d'euros
sur ce milliard promis pour pouvoir
mettre en place un certain nombre
d'actions invita création d'un fonds
spécifique de 200 millions qui je vous
le rappelle depuis a reçu un avis
contraire du gouvernement n'a pas tu n'a
donc pas été retenue mais des moyens
spécifiques dans les parcours emploi
compétences la création de 80 sites et
de l'emploi supplémentaire et un zoom
très très important sur ce qui était de
l'éducatif c'est à dire 50 % de
programmes en plus sur la réussite
éducative 40 sites éducatifs
supplémentaires 150% sur les fonds de la
santé et une nouvelle impulsion pour le
n aime pas les rues et le collectif
reste mobilisé pour voir émerger un
conseil national des solutions le
premier aura lieu à roubaix on février
sera parrainée par jean louis borloo
ancien ministre de la ville qui avait
créé un plan pour les quartiers
populaires et d'ici là le collectif a
prévu de se rassembler ce jeudi 17
décembre devant l'assemblée nationale et
date je vous le disais du vote du projet
de loi de finances 2011 21 dans
l'actualité du jour également le
confinement est remplacée depuis ce
mardi par un couvre-feu il sera effectif
de 20 heures à 6 heures du matin hors de
cette plage horaire vous pouvez donc de
nouveau vous déplacer sans attestation
en revanche de 20 heures à 6 heures du
matin les sorties doivent être limités
au strict minimum et muni d'une
attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
les motifs sont affichés tout ce qui est
à trait aux trajets professionnels
l'aide aux personnes vulnérables
notamment ou encore la sortie de votre
animal de compagnie pour cela limite
d'une heure dans un
lyon d'un kilomètre plus d'informations
notamment sur les motifs valables sur le
site du gouvernement
et vous le savez le 24 décembre fait
exception il n'y aura pas de couvre feu
cette nuit là pour pouvoir aller fêter
noël en famille et à dix jours de
l'échéance le conseil scientifique a
émis quelques recommandations pour
limiter la propagation du kof 19 s'auto
confiné notamment une semaine avant le
repas et avoir recours à un test
quelques jours avant pour les personnes
symptomatique ou pour celle qui juge
avoir pris un risque et dans cette
actualité un nouveau centre de dépistage
vient d'ouvrir dans le sud yvelines il
est installé dans une taille ni house
apporta appartenant à la commune du à
perray-en-yvelines ce site mobile va
sillonner 16 communes rurales dans le
mois le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet
une taille gnahou ce lieu insolite dans
lequel la mairie du perray-en-yvelines a
installé un centre de dépistage du coc
vite 19 mobile cet équipement va
parcourir pendant un mois minimum
c'est ce communes de l'agglomération
rambouillet territoire et bien les gens
vont souvent à trappes ou parfois vont à
rambouillet où il ya de la tente
donc on a décidé nous mêmes de mettre en
place notre dispositif qui est assez
unique s'est adapté particulièrement à
la ruralité ou personne
aucune de nos communes n'aurions pu
avoir ce propre centre de test re si
nous n'avions pas eu ni nos forces
cette taille ni house prend ses
quartiers les mercredi et samedi sur la
place de la mairie du perray en yvelines
ce jour là il n'y avait presque que des
habitants de la commune qui sont venus
effectuer un test pcr
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était une très
bonne initiative c'était très
intéressant de permettre plusieurs fois
par semaine aux gens de la commune de
pouvoir venir se faire tester et
agréable spacieux c'est aéré et puis les
gens sont super sympas aussi ce centre
de dépistage était aussi l'occasion de
sortir cette taille ni house qui dormait
sur un parking
depuis deux ans et acheté 30 mille euros
par la précédente municipalité
ça va
en lien avec le prestataire loxam inde
deux aides soignantes ont la charge de
réaliser les tests mois avant que
j'arrive je doutais un peu
je savais pas ce que c'était dangereux
jamais fait dans ce genre d'endroit et
finalement fut si c'est bien pratique
environ 100 tests sont réalisés par jour
un dispositif faciliter aussi grâce aux
subventions de la région ile-de-france
santé également mais à guyancourt un don
du sang ait eu lieu hier l'objectif
faire face à la baisse des réserves de
produits sanguins est d'autres collectes
sont d'ailleurs organisées dans les
prochains jours à saint quentin en
yvelines célia gars tsongo 45 minutes
pour sauver 3 vies
le don du sang est vital pour les
malades une collecte avait lieu hier
lundi 14 décembre à la maison de
quartier auguste renoir à guyancourt
en ce moment nous n'avons pas trop le
choix de la typologie des collectes
puisqu'on ne peut pas aller dans les
universités on ne peut plus aller
pratiquement dès les entreprises de fria
pas à ses demandes
donc nous organisons ce qu'on appelle
des collectes de communes et nous
donnant la possibilité aux personnes qui
habitent dans le voisinage de venir
directement sur le lieu de la collecte
avec la crise sanitaire les collectes de
sang ont été désorganisée et les
donneurs ont été moins nombreux le but
de ces collectes et donc de recueillir
un maximum de dons avant les fêtes on
s'inquiète pour les semaines qui vont
arriver puisque justement on va alléger
le confinement va pouvoir sortir un peu
plus changer de région donc il ya les
vacances il ya les fêtes mais il faut
penser aux malades et il faut venir
donner son sang
d'habitude je donne à mon travail mais
là quand on fait télétravail du coup je
donne
dans ma vie quoi en fait dans les sols
ont mis à disposition c'est important
d'aider les gens et puis si ça peut
rendre service c'est tout bénéfique et
pour ceux qui auraient peur de venir le
port du masque est obligatoire
les distanciation sociales sont
respectés et du gel hydro alcoolique est
à disposition à toutes les étapes
comme nous avons des rendez vous ou
gérons les flux c'est très important il
n'y a pas de deyme lüthi nation de
donneurs grâce au rendez vous aux gestes
barrières et bien sûr si ronald qu'ovide
en ce moment on ne se présente pas sur
la collecte
il faudra attendre 28 jours après la
guérison pour venir donner son sang
d'autres collectes auront lieu ces
prochains jours dans de nombreuses
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
comme à elancourt jeudi 17 décembre à
montigny le bretonneux vendredi 18
décembre ou encore villepreux dimanche
20 décembre un début décembre le
téléthon enregistré 836 1000 euros de
promesses de dons dans le département un
chiffre en baisse par rapport aux années
précédentes en raison de l'annulation
des animations pour cette édition
épidémie oblige
mais la générosité se poursuit en faveur
de l'événement contre pour pour la
recherche contre les maladies génétiques
rares à guyancourt le week-end dernier
l'association les jardins passions
partage préparer des repas à emporter
les bénéfices reversés au téléthon
le reportage d'astrid bergère et de
nicolas landré l'association jardins
passions partage basé à guyancourt a
innové
d'habitude elle a un stand le week-end
du téléthon mais cette année face aux
mesures sanitaires
les membres ont décidé de préparer des
repas destinés à la vente
trois opérations eu lieu en juillet en
novembre et la dernière ce week-end et
pour préparer la centaine de repas il a
fallu s'organiser
la préparation s'est depuis dix jours on
est allé deux fois à papier dans le
dans le 13ème au quartier asiatique pour
acheter nos produits c'est un peu moins
cher qu ici on n'a plus beaucoup de
choix
on a fait des stockage des produits secs
ici puis après on est allé à différents
ma présence ici pour acheter des fruits
des légumes de la viande sa home unis
cette fois des plats asiatiques
entièrement préparée par l'équipe le
pâté de crabes fait maison
les nouilles sautées fait par mon amie
alice après on a fait la salade de
fruits on acheter des fruits en boîte
exotique on a coupé en plus des ananas
des mangues des fruits de la passion des
kiwis en plus pour le compléter
après on a fait j'ai fait des cookies
les coquelicots cacahuètes au sésame aux
jambes et ça fonctionne le menu complet
était à 20 euros une façon de manger un
bon repas et de contribuer à la
recherche médicale et en plus c'est pour
une bonne cause tout ce qu'est le
téléthon que derrière et comme les
activités du téléthon cette année en
extérieur c'est un peu limité et ben
j'en suis
troisième repas que je fais pour le
téléthon au total avec ces trois
opérations de drive europa et quelques
ventes supplémentaires l'association a
récolté un peu plus de 3000 euros
intégralement reversés au téléthon
[Musique]
le noël c'est dans dix jours et s'il ya
bien une chose qui ne changera pas cette
année malgré la crise sanitaire ce sont
les cadeaux au pied du sapin pour les
enfants la mode est néanmoins au retour
au gland au grand classique dans les
listes au père noël
les dernières tendances avec mélanie
poké et bixente mais rien senti très
bonne 10 livres ayora parce qu'ils
aiment bien lire mes enfants et puis des
jeux de construction playmobil barbie
mais surtout légaux ces noms reviennent
souvent parmi les demandes des clients
dans les magasins de jouets les
enseignes attendait la période des fêtes
de pied ferme pour attraper une année
compliquée vous avez les franchises qui
fonctionne bien comme lego mario comme
star wars qui fonctionne toujours très
bien où harry potter mais on a les
gammes propre à lego avec toute la gamme
city qui est donc l'organisation de la
ville des pompiers des aéroports de la
police qui fonctionne aussi toujours
très très bien c'est que le classicisme
qui reprend les valeurs sûres
du classique donc tels que le monopoly
le cluedo et autres jeux de société
une catégorie qui a beaucoup de succès
grâce aux habitudes prises par les
français pendant le confinement on a
également des jeux de la société à ce
mode et qui est basé à guyancourt
donc nous faisons dans la proximité
beaucoup de jeux des skates game 2
enquête policière de
découverte de trésors de choses comme ça
fait souci pour les retardataires les
rayons sont pleins et prêt à supporter
les demandes de chacun une bonne
nouvelle pour les enfants également
qu'ils ne seront pas oubliés au pied du
sapin il va y avoir des jouets parce que
après l'année quand même très
particulière que tout le monde a vécu à
cause de la pandémie
les enfants seront probablement très
gâtés au pied du sapin les magasins de
jouets sont donc de retour
il mise beaucoup sur l'activité de noël
représentant 65% du chiffre d'affaires
de l'année
prenons à présent notre machine à
voyager dans le temps pour parler du
jouet ancien qui a encore son mot à dire
françois binétruy est avec nous en
visioconférence bonsoir enfin alors vous
êtes collectionneur basé à versailles
collectionneur de jouets d'optique
depuis l'âge de 7 ans et depuis 40 ans
depuis l'année 1981 vous vendez des jeux
et des jouets anciens
depuis quelques années d'ailleurs un ses
ventes se font exclusivement en ligne
déjà pourquoi cette passion d'où vient
la passion du jouet ancien alors assez
assez bêtement d'une rencontre de deux
joué quand j'avais 6 ou 7 ans mon père
étant à quelqu'un qui avait beaucoup
dans les brocantes de l'époque et des
découvertes de jouer quand j'avais 6 ou
7 ans qui m'ont amené dès cet âge là à
devenir collectionneur puis marchand
depuis mes 20 ans il le disait vous êtes
collectionneur plus particulièrement de
jouer d'optique
qu'est ce qu'un jouet daube city dans
les jeux d'optique c'est tout ce qui a
amené au cinéma aujourd'hui ce sont des
jouets qui ont débuté pratiquement dans
tour du dix septième siècle avec les
anamorphoses avec les lanternes magiques
avec les boîtes optique puis ensuite 19e
les premiers jouets qui ont fait le
mouvement ça se termine beaucoup en
scope phénakistiscope thaumatrope un
praxinoscope autres
et qui a amené en 1895 au chili dans les
images qui s'affiche actuellement on a
vu notamment un jouet optique mais il
s'agit d'un petit éventail de votre
large collection vous proposer à la
vente on aura l'occasion d'en parler
tout à l'heure d'après vous quel est le
charme du jouet ancien par rapport à ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui quel est son
charme aux jouets anciens
alors moi je comparerais pas ce qui se
fera par rapport à ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui je dirais que l'intérêt du
jouet ancien c'est que le jouet a
toujours été une image de son époque
c'est ce que j'ai aimé c'est un témoin
de l'époque
finalement le joueur absolument et c'est
très intéressant parce que par exemple
les jeux de cartes aux sous la
révolution française les rois les reines
été supprimés pour être remplacés par
d'autres figures les jouets de guerre de
1870 de 1914 et même pendant la guerre
de 39-45 des jeux ou des jouets ont été
faits aura en relation avec ces guerres
et les jouets en réalité sont vraiment
un reflet très important de l'histoire
de leur époque
est ce qu'aujourd'hui il ya encore de
nombreux adeptes des jeux anciens ou
est-ce que ça se perd finalement alors
entre les deux il y encore énormément de
collectionneurs mais bien évidemment il
y a une certaine évolution c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il va y avoir des
collectionneurs de goldorak ou de la
star wars ce qui n'existait évidemment
pas il ya 50 ans évolue au fil des
années alors votre fond je le disais est
très large il ya des jeux datant du
xviie siècle jusqu'à la seconde guerre
mondiale des jouets du xviiie jusqu'aux
années 1970
qu'est ce que vous vendez mettez nous un
peu l'eau à la bouche
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous vendez
en termes de jouets et de jeux alors
évidemment il ya le grand classique ce
sont ce les dinky toys les petites
voitures
c'est certainement le même depuis
collectionné au mans il ya les salles de
cours qui reste huitième siècle jusqu'à
maintenant un sujet
parmi les plus collectionner au monde
aussi c'est pas forcément à presque tout
le monde apprécie moins à perdre et
parlant que j'aime beaucoup les jeux moi
j'aime beaucoup les jeux déchets j'ai
beaucoup les jeux de cartes
justement parce qu'ils sont toujours en
relation avec leur époque mais des dinky
toys sont également en relation avec
leur époque avec leur époque
il est évident que les collectionneurs
de 80 ans collectionne les dinky toys
des années 50 et les plus jeunes ont
collectionné les titres des années 70
une adaptation la question qui fâche
peut-être est-ce que ça coûte cher de
s'offrir un jouet ou un jeu ancien où il
ya finalement pour tous les prix ça peut
coûter très cher mais on peut aussi
faire une très jolie collection à très
cher c'est à dire que la gamme de prix
va commencer à quelques dizaines d'euros
pour monter jusqu'à quelques centaines
voire 1000 ou 2000 euros pour avoir déjà
une très très jolie collection très
correct maintenant bien évidemment il y
à déjouer comme dans tout comme dans les
tableaux comme dans tout il ya des
jouets qui valent extrêmement cher et on
retrouve votre boutique en ligne via le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci françois binétruy d'avoir est avec
nous merci beaucoup
rappel vous êtes marchands de jeux et de
jouets anciens et vous êtes basé à
versailles
c'est l'un des rares marchés de noël à
avoir été maintenu à maurepas 1500
personnes sont venues acheter quelques
cadeaux prendre une photo avec le père
noël ce week-end retour sur cet
événement
dans un contexte aussi particulier avec
eléonore sinoquet nicolas d'andrus il a
eu lieu du 11 au 13 décembre le
traditionnel marché de noël de maurepas
fait partie des rares animations des
fêtes de fin d'année à avoir été
maintenu à saint quentin en yvelines
il y avait une vraie demande des
commerçants et comme la préfecture ne
l'a autorisé avec bien sûr des
mesures sanitaires incontournable c'est
un choix politique mais nous avons fait
également show politique de ne pas
maintenir la patinoire
ni les activités pour les enfants ni la
chorale ni l'inauguration pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de rassemblement trop important
pas plus de deux cent quarante six
personnes en même temps et des
infections obligatoire des mains des
contraintes sanitaires strictes met en
marche est maintenue pour le plus grand
bonheur des commerçants en cette période
particulière c'est pour nous montre pour
montrer aussi con on existe parce qu'il
ya plein de gens qui savent pas qu'on
existe sur mort paraît coignières donc
ça en bon moyen de se montrer surtout
c'est le seul qui qui est en haut on
peut être présent et ça fait du bien de
pouvoir avoir ce contact là qu'on n'a
pas eu lieu depuis des mois et qui nous
manque
mille cinq cents personnes sont venues
pour ce traditionnel marché de noël
wes le plaisir avec ce contexte est tous
assez c'est vraiment agréable cependant
de changer un peu les idées et puis on
trompe les traditions habituel quoi ce
que le marché noël est très sympa y
aller l'esprit de noël
ça reste un petit marché mais ça c'est
important quand même de les avoir
maintenus avec le co vite on peut pas
trop
sortir du coup ça fait du bien de 2
se promener dans les marchés de noël
un marché réussie pour la municipalité
et qui a permis d'avoir un peu l'esprit
de noël dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire
justement pour refermer ce journal un
mot de la star du moment qui prépare sa
grande tournée c'est le père noël bien
sûr que nous avons croisé à maurepas
est-ce que les cadeaux seront bien prêt
à temps cette année voici sa réponse
faut savoir que c'est compliqué comme
pour tout le monde mais
tout se passe bien les enfants recevront
leurs cadeaux comme tous les lutteurs
sont en train de travailler aussi
masqués comme moi et pensez bien à vous
protéger c'est très important les
enfants nous voilà rassurés merci c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
belle soirée à tous avec tv 78
[Musique]